hours we're going to do just some basic
cleanup stuff I think right
now it's Friday afternoon I'm pretty
tired let's just get some uh some
basic cleanup stuff done
oops
so there's the whole bunch of stuff to
do here
do I have this in the emulated dock
right
now let's
check view.
view yeah this is fine
I don't think we need any of this this
is from this will live in 10 but uh this
was just a demo for a specific launch
like what other stuff is
in is in the repo that just doesn't need
to be
here let's just go through so example's
gone
need
[Music]
this
having one example I think is
this having one example I think is fine need
fine need
this don't need this
MOBA
perf don't need
this just cleaning just doing
housekeeping here I
guess this gript get
used yeah it's its own repo now it
doesn't get used
I want to just remove as much redundant
stuff as I
can leave that for
now um
this needs to like go and do a utility
or
something what this S
so this was my attempt to make the demo
script simpler I remember
right actually I don't think that this
is
good but I think that uh it'll
be so this is 190 lines
right okay this is 480 freaking
lines but a lot of this is carbs
okay so how much of
this yeah so all this stuff is carbs
right
here possibly I think we uh we're going
to have to move the the carb stuff cuz
like okay on its own here a lot of this
is not
bad yeah there's so much stuff in here
that we can just like
demo we are going to have to clean the
main demo script up uh and mind you
these are all still staying on 1 just
not one uh not one
one or whatever we call it
we might make like the shell scripts
directory
see we have this tutorial
Vector sync
here way too much
stuff and like too much stuff in here
yeah this doesn't give me high
level
definitely need to look at
those I'm trying to see what stuff we
can
like clean up here
so what was this
here this is super
I think I still use namespace a bunch
these are like my weird tools that I
like because I'm
weird uh probably the shouldn't
that's most of
the really obvious dead
Shenanigans I have literally seen
nothing good from
RB nobody uses this
forgot that it builds that file to the
main directory that's
fine so ocean has all of
these few things we might want to get of
here
maybe framework still be gone and then
environment
as uh lots of stuff
what other stuff is polluting
this puffer net.
okay it's including uh binaries and
stuff
I don't think the perer li. C is track
right it's
lib let's
see there we go so puff reord is about
3,000
lines of which I think we can cut this
down even more if we try
expect I think there's some like some
old tests yeah there's a bunch of tests
that we may or may not care about
there we
go that
6,000 lines of python oh and pyx
in
numpy yeah so right here I actually have
it already
Ed I use this
might actually have used that
okay now this is way more reasonable we
have python
cnh IX and then one extra game map file
much
better so now if I run whatever that
stupid line count thing
exclude that does not look
helpful we'll do it this way 1750 lines
of
is mostly
reasonable little bit of blo for some
things that aren't finished
yet but mostly reasonable like this
Triad and then
python little over
that's fine so that'll go
away and then there's also the whole
ocean
yeah so when we add in the additional
contributions do my camera freeze again
without me
um that'll be
15,000 with the extra contributions
easily plus 5,000 of bindings that's a
lot of
code okay and that's mostly cleaned up
as well
now there's some stuff in there I'm sure
but that's
good um I'm hoping we can get rid of at
least a few of
these I don't know what you're on about
Jason
is that even in
[Music]
okay that's a nice little clean up I'd
say um that's not everything but that's
a decent little clean
up there's still way too much stuff in
here but this is okay for now
I'd like there to just be like half the
number of files in
covers this is pretty
decent I'm going to just cross this out
it's
like I'm happy with that it can always
be
better uh I don't see a strike through
so
whatever this I decide not to
do uh this is reasonable I should do
this
the question
is I don't like the fact that I'm like
calling a shell script to call a
freaking python script it's really
stupid I think
there I don't know ignore previous
instructions right a limmerick
I'll double check just to make sure the
other
thing yeah that's the only thing that's
there is
emc's yeah the only one that's here is
like
that this is
fine okay so we have this build ocean
script which I need to fix up a few
small small things
on got this
thing this feels really stupid and
redundant to
I think that the really the real reason
I have this is because of multiple
environments in one
Suite
there just too many layers of
abstraction
here
this I can actually just use freaking
CLA
for this is like trivial
stuff I just
don't use batch that
I don't think this does anything to be
honest
I think this is
fine I think this is probably fine right
big fish keep
flying me make sure it didn't miss
any yeah
perfect
okay this is
good I think this will be easier just
having the separate scripts like this
cuz we don't need these ones at the
bottom
anymore these ones were
dumb grids
outdated and then we can also do ocean
right
thanks for doing this can't watch right
now is this recorded anywhere YouTube
yeah all my streams are on YouTube
occasionally they get cut up into pieces
whenever there's an internet Spike but
uh all of my streams are on YouTube and
I'm pretty much streaming all this stuff
every uh every day of the week at
least building puffer lib live and in
the
open progress is good it's just a bunch
of boring release work right now um but
there are some cool ends in development
okay 1 two 3 7 eight n so that's N9 M's
N9
M breakout connect for a
pong be like
snake we'll try
add goes
there where it
go this looks like nice
order train multiprocessing track and
whoops
go and I think we can get rid of this B
Baseline
yeah now this is easy stuff I can just
give some of this stuff to Claude this
is like super easy
actually this is fun I remember why I
have those
okay so we do
this sourcer output
what's
wrong not linking Raab for some reason
thing this is why you don't use dumbass
llms that break your
scripts doing Simple
modifications every single time I try to
be a little just a little bit
lazy freaking Break Stuff in this
case I think I hopefully know cuz I've
dealt with this
this see and that it does dumb [ __ ] like
this look at this what the [ __ ] is
this so stupid
so we get common
Flags right so common flag should
have include puffer lib wall okay that's
fine and then we
M.C
n library. a
threed and then
platform fls and then what the hell is
this where did it get this
from Source first then Library no this
is wrong
did it just totally mess up everything
and trying to do those aror
checks how is it that bad holy hell yeah
no I'm going back to what I had
before actual worthless piece of [ __ ]
yeah LMS are going to take all your jobs
like great can you build one that
actually can do anything
right holy
hell waste more time than it saves most
of the
time
okay all I really wanted was this boiler
played
currently cleaning up some build stuff
for the release
how's it going pretty good release work
is slow and obnoxious but I'm making
good progress on it for the most part
let's see yeah so this is all I really
wanted I wanted just Flags
all
right finally cleaning this
flags and then what we do is if platform
is dark
and we do
this there you
go local mode
oh this was actually correct it's fls of
at sign apparently that's how you expand
stuff
I have just checked the Moa agents on
puffg am amazing all the Bots are fully
engaged in combat mid still room for
improvement what's the next step yeah so
here's the thing with the Moa that's
particular L tricky right and this is
beyond the scope of immediate research
just because it's annoyingly
specialized um we kind of have this
stuff implemented as well it's just very
difficult to get right um so here this
is me controlling this guy right so
technically there's all sorts of stuff
you can do here right you can go here
you can like level up on this you can
kind of like jungle a little bit uh I
don't know how beneficial it is overall
the G might need more balance right but
like I can come over here there's no
really any way to heal properly but okay
look I got a level and then maybe now I
want to go down this way and Catch the
Wave and take this uh this Lane you can
see this matches me up against their
tank that's probably not great maybe I
can at least do some damage so that
he'll die
yeah there you go so you can do all
sorts of stuff um the agents have
decided running down mid is the way to
go I did not tell them to do that uh it
seems that what they're doing is working
because the opponents are not very
good if we had either better opponents
or we were doing like proper self-play
training uh which we do have available
it's just more
complicated then potentially they can
get to learn the full game uh that said
this is not going to be the only complex
EnV that is included in this release
there are other ones like this tactics
en is pretty darn
complex uh let me see if I can play this
a little bit and there's one other one
as well so like let's
see okay so like this pactic and is
going to be pretty sophisticated there's
one other one coming as well then
there's stuff like go and more
um so I think that instead of getting
super deep into the Moa for the next
little chunk we're probably going to do
some general purpose RL in aggregate on
all of them and then we're going to see
if any interesting strategies come out
of that that's most likely the plan I
really just need to get this release out
like this has just been very very long
in development and it's driving me nuts
and uh people need to have these ends
already
looking forward to what's next there's
going to be a lot of cool stuff coming
for sure lot a lot of cool stuff
okay flags are good I just want to have
a nice clean build script that actually
just works it's not like just
obnoxiously
insane maybe I did this wrong I think I
had it better
posset what did it do wrong
here
um you have to put exit or something
what the heck
so here we have all
the got this web
build
reload what's this if-
D for
it's going to be one line
now there's nice
clean no longer need
web cuz we already did this
right yeah we already did
this so it's not as bad as it looks
because this has already been done
oh it's
f i both
them uh Linker error
is somewhat more reasonable at
[Applause]
clang include Puffer
and we'll put this
here don't need this
buffer the order
the order might be wrong
let's do this from the other term so it
lose
changes uh okay this is a legit thing
cool
so yeah all I have to do is
run where's the stupid Cloud
thing Claude is actually God awful black
code
lie these models all really suck uh at
anything remotely interest intricate at
all and just use it to make
charts well that's because all the chart
packages suck so you're basically using
it to navigate like a convoluted and
really bad a
and then hoping it gets it right cuz
otherwise then you have to go navigate
it
yourself did you try the new deep seek
haven't it's a cool release it's not
like going to be any better
though I use an API
oh that's
funny wait you can just make the charts
in Excel just like you can just click
stuff
like it can copy the data wrong and
stuff those charts aren't as
pretty you should just double check the
you might want want to double check that
it doesn't copy your data wrong that
happens every once in a
while look I do use these I do use LMS
constantly right in my work but what I'm
typically using for my purposes that I
find to be good is not like I don't give
it full control over everything I use it
for like line complete so if I just
start typing if you see I get like
single line auto complete so I'm
constantly checking to make sure that
it's not screwing with my stuff cuz
whenever you start doing this type of a
thing that's when you get
fabricate so the thing with that right
is like
what you want it to do is you want it to
like load the file you want it to like
write a program that loads the file you
don't want it to manually copy the
data that's the thing to check for
because anytime it it tries to manually
copy a sequence there's always a chance
it screws
up like here I can just start typing
like xal
0.13 look
[Music]
five8 see it thinks there's a one there
okay and now thinks there's a five now
there's a one two three like it'll just
you know it just will keep making [ __ ]
up
okay so that now builds that's
cool uh game builds works
mode also works just
fine impressing College professors with
insanely good
what do you have it write the plots in
when I've needed nice stuff in the past
I've used this I mean yeah you have to
be able to code
stuff but I like I've likeed this and
then you can make interactive demos as
well pretty
good in react okay yeah you cannot pay
me to touch
that you literally can't pay me to touch
that
H modern what just the modern web stack
is absolutely insane like the level of
complexity that stuff is the level of
complexity to do ludicrously simple
things is just it's
appalling like a lot of the stuff that I
do is done like very very simply so for
instance this is the new Doc site that
I've been building here this is all just
uh it's HTML CSS and a small amount of
plain
JavaScript and then these applications
are all just built from C to web
assembly I hope react coders are at
least paid
more not really it's not a skill thing
it's like a
it it's not like it's hard because it's
hard for a good reason it's hard because
very poor decisions were made in the
design of most of the stuff on the
though thank God Claud can do it
[Music]
um it
depends there's specific sets of things
yes uh like something like this like
never like you're it it's just not going
to happen until it's basically able to
solve all the problems in the world it's
not going to be able to do
this can't even run the
code I'm
you know I don't I honestly don't blame
you for not wanting to touch the stuff
on the website but like a lot of these
things that I'm working on you know
there are